انطلق في مدينه شرم الشيخ المصريه مؤتمر
المناقب 27 الذي يعقد باشراف الامم
المتحده وبمشاركه واسعه لزعماء ورؤساء
وخبراء من 200 دوله
من اجل المناخ بات مساله حياه او موت لامن
العالم وفي كلمته خلال افتتاح اعمال القمه
قال وزير الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري ان
بلاده لن تدخر جهدا في قياده العمل الدولي
لمواجهه التغير المناخي
كما اقرب رئيس المصريه عبد الفتاح السيسي
عن صخره واعتزازه باستضافه مصر لفعاليات
الدوره السابعه والعشرين من مؤتمر الاطراف
لاتفاقيه الامم المتحده بمدينه شرم الشيخ
كوب 27 الايطاليه حول تغير المناخ قال
الرئيس السيسي في سلسله تغريدات على تويتر
ان الدوره الحاليه من قمه المناخ تاتي في
توقيت حساس للغايه يتعرض فيه عالمنا
لاخطار وجوديه وتحديات غير مسبوقه تؤثر
على بقائك كوكبنا وقدرتنا على المعيشه
عليه
تستلزم تحركا سريعا من كافه الدول لوضع
خريطه طريق تحمل العالم من تاثيره
التغيرات المناخيه واكد ان بلاده تتطلعه
لخروج المؤتمر من مرحله الوعود الى مرحله
التنفيذ باجراءات ملموسه على الارض
تبني على ما سبق لا سيما مخرجات قمه
الجلاسكو واتفاق باريس